i look through some camera
they do like the intestinal come on man
type camera on my eye
um what the [ __ ] is that and then uh
they give it to him and go before they
looked in my eye i was like oh yeah man
technical difficulties i'm so sorry we
will be right back
with the podcast yeah sorry my [ __ ]
discord crashed
oh were you just talking i mean yeah i
was just talking to myself it's fine
damn i should have just logged off as a
prank and just let me just do a 20
minute bit yeah
20 minute story 20 minute story at the
end so you're like yeah so it turns out
my retina is actually
detached and i have eye cancer and it's
just really tough man
welcome back to the podcast uh my
discord credit i miss
all of that what were you saying dude
we're saying about your [ __ ] ass eyes
sorry so start start again i was just
gonna say the last time i was at that
guy's place
i used the hand sanitizer and he looked
at me he said alcohol free
and i was like oh is that good i was
like oh good in my head and then i was
like wait no don't you want alcohol
how is it sanitizing i don't understand
i mean the other sanitizer they were
using was alcoholic for sure i thought i
was going to pass out putting my head
up to those machines because all i could
smell was
that [ __ ] um wait wait wait
my [ __ ] stream labs crap what the
[ __ ] is going on
oh oh oh dude this is me
hold on one second computer
[ __ ] oh here's the beautiful part i
actually have all this on my side
so your technical
um uh experience
your uh i don't have
that you're living yeah as i i have your
audio of all that we have this recording
no my audio is fine you don't have my
video though there we go we're back
okay we're back we're back nate just do
a little magic let's put like a picture
of
a i don't know um yeah put it like a
toucan or something
yeah what do i look like who do i look
like the you know the the the penguin
from surf's up
yeah yeah i put the penguin from surf's
up yeah his name is whose name is cody
by the way
yeah um so bro so whatever
um i tell him i started boxing recently
and then he gets the little scan from my
eye and
bro he just goes oh i got some bad news
i was like oh you had to say it like
that
like but i mean i guess it was nicer you
know
then was it like how do i how do i put
this
this is your retina and this is the
attachment
right
it's busted
so something busted that thing wide open
[Laughter]
retinas falling down falling down
falling down i thought of that one on
the way over here uh your retina is
[ __ ] up
um sorry now what was the bad news
we'll see you guys i got some bad news
man and my [ __ ] stomach sinks i'm
like don't say it and he's like
looks like you have a detached retina i
go [ __ ]
really and then and then i say it
and he said you said you were boxing
right and i was like yeah but i don't do
it like professionally like
i didn't take some type of like head
injury you know i'm like i'm just
hitting pads
and he goes oh all right we'll lie down
over here and he's like let me do an
ultrasound so
he checks if my eye is pregnant
and he's like scanning around my eye and
he goes oh all right good news man
um i was wrong i dodged a bullet there
um and he's like he's like your retina
is attached see like look at all this
and my retina is
it is attached but my retina is lifted
off the back of my eye so i'm like what
the [ __ ]
so like from memory he's like oh you
have like
cor you know the optimus corpus whatever
it was like some
crazy latin [ __ ] he just knew it by
memory which was i was like this is
i mean like i've never seen a doctor do
that you know what i mean like i
know that [ __ ] but to just like type it
out like yeah regular speed to be like
oh yeah you
that's have every doctor has this
keyboard too yeah
so yeah so he
types the [ __ ] in and um
i guess it's a he's like it's very it's
super common in in
men where when some men when they get
like stressed out or something
a uh a liquid forms in the back
like and it like lifts the retina off
the back of the eyelid and it goes away
over time
um he was like did you lose a job or did
you do anything stressful and i started
laughing like
could you imagine if i had actually lost
a job and that was his first question to
me
[Laughter]
yeah it sounds like you're stressed out
man did you lose a job actually yes i
just did get fired
um yeah today literally before i came
here thank you for reminding me yeah
cool and i also can't afford to cover
this because i no longer have
insurance because they wouldn't offer me
cobra that is a pretty funny question to
ask
you think you'd like ease into that a
little bit or a little bit more
with that just left and right did you
did your wife
like start [ __ ] around on you or
something like
you kind of look like you see with me i
give that good pipe so that'll never
happen to me but for someone like you i
feel like
you might be cheated on when you're
lying down on the table i noticed like
your dick print is very small
so the first thing that came to me is
like you must you must have been cheated
on because your dick looks extremely
small
you can see it through my scrubs here
it's actually a massive problem and
that's also what they call my dick it's
a massive problem but that's besides the
point
um is your wife [ __ ] around on you
yeah yeah oh wait
oh [ __ ] sherry oh she comes wow oops um
never mind
uh yeah exactly he recognized her
oh oh oh that's your wife oh my three
o'clock wow
yikes we're gonna get you on out of here
then yeah sorry bud sorry about
that sorry i had to find out this way
this happens mostly because of stress do
you have a whacked dick by chance
what you know sure
predict it's kind of weak it's kind of
weak right
weak stroke game yeah so something maybe
you don't last long
yeah you don't know what to do with it
yeah and you're unemployed maybe
yeah that's what i mean this guy was
just
going raw on me left and right oh man
your eyes [ __ ] up did you get fired
yeah i gotta i got a great therapist if
you need if you need someone to talk to
you
he's just next door man and i get a 20
referral so you know if you head down
there yeah exactly
oh that's funny well i mean that's
fortunate i guess your
eyes fine and your retinas attached yeah
but that is also interesting isn't it
crazy how much uh stress can do to your
body
i know like the physical effects of
stress yeah how they manifest
yeah it's kind of scary you know ladies
and gentlemen like fellas if you go to
hook up and
your dick is not working right it's
stress man the stress is just
killing my [ __ ] right now or inverse
ladies you know if if you're
if you just can't get into it and you're
kind of dry like it's the stress i'm
sorry
i think you just use that blanket for
anything yeah i mean
yeah ladies if you have a dap yeah
you've got a doubt
it's just the stress from my job sorry
yeah the stress is just that's
absolutely a valid excuse that many
people use i bet you
[Laughter]
is not the sea isn't that just the [ __ ]
you see like in movies and stuff it's
like
a long day long day yeah yeah get into
it you know yeah
i just think it's funny to use that at
like two in the morning
yeah yeah yeah drinking yeah a long
night of drinking and she's like oh
just it's just my job man you know
job really stressed out
it's nothing to do with you absolutely
nothing to do with you
yeah it's just the stress no it actually
is when
when he said when he said that i laughed
i said stress can
[ __ ] your eyes up that's crazy
you